-Our first guest tonight
hosts the Emmy
and Peabody Award-winning show
"Last Week Tonight."
Not a single Oscar, though
Nobody talks about that.
[ Laughter ]
Not even nominated.
Snubbed.
Airs Sunday nights on HBO and is
available to stream on HBO Max
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend, John Oliver.
How are you, John?
-Yeah, where's my Oscar?
-Yeah.
-I was --
I was the voice of Vanity Smurf.
If that's not Oscar-worthy
what is?
-You've done a lot of voice work
and not a single --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Nothing.
I've been Vanity Smurf,
I've been a porcupine,
I've been a bird.
Come on.
That's -- that's range.
That's --
Also, talking about range,
I was watching "A Closer Look"
then as you were doing it.
-Yeah.
-For someone who insists,
"Oh, I don't do impression
at 'SNL,'"
the way you transition
from Kevin McCarthy to Ted Cru
to Lindsey Graham, it was like
Rich Little at the Bellagio.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-It was smooth.
So smooth.
-You know what?
I -- I certainly am gettin
a little
"at the Bellagio" response..
[ Laughter ]
...here from my studio crew.
-Just cutlery?
-You know, I look back,
and I feel like Lorne just
did not recognize my talent.
And I think...
-Yeah.
-...were he ever
to stumble upon this show...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...you know?
-If he does --
Well, we know that won't happen.
But if he is watching,
it's not about --
it's not sounding like them,
it's embodying.
That was Daniel Day Lewis
doing impressions.
The spirit
of all three men transition --
"I don't do impressions."
-Yeah.
Well, it's hard.
'Cause, you know, I come hom
from a long day's work,
and I have to say to my wife
"Alexi, I'm Ted right now.
I'm gonna need some time.
I'm gonna need time to --
Seth -- Seth's not here yet.
-When you're reading a -- when
you're reading a story to Ashe
does he ever say, "And now
as Kevin McCarthy, please?
"Sure.
I just need 15 minutes."
-Yeah.
"First, Dad, do Jim Jordan
telling me about
Curious George."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, we're --
-That's what every child wants
isn't it?
"Do it as Jim Jordan."
[ Laughter ]
I just want --
I just want this story
to contextually have
a very different memory for me
in the future.
[ Laughter ]
-I've complimented you
time and time again
during this difficult year
on your choice to do your show
in the beautiful limbo
that you're in front of now.
But yet audiences might be
making their way back.
How are you feeling about that
-I mean, you know, it was --
it was weird to be without the
for about a show and a half.
-Yep.
-And then, honestly, I've got --
I have got used to it, if I'm --
if I'm totally honest.
I mean, I generally barrel
through them anyway,
also as someone who did stand-up
for a long time.
I am --
I did stand-up in Britain,
so I am used
to delivering jokes to silence
It's almost
how I'm more comfortable.
-Yeah.
-So it's the sound
that I anticipate,
and when it comes back,
actually, I feel nothing.
-Yeah.
Well, I think that you and I
are similar in that almost -
when a joke goes too well,
we think...
-Yeah.
-...collectively the audienc
is wrong, and we then
begin to doubt ourselves.
-There was --
I will say there are --
Normally, the happiest you wil
see me in a split second
is if a joke I've loved
has just bombed.
And I think --
I feel like I've seen
the same with you where it's -
your face will kind of glow --
-[ Laughs ]
-...as you send the joke
that you -- that you love
to its inevitable death.
It's just --
The only thing that is --
that is going to be really
useful for us is occasionally,
when we occasionally do
something very big,
like unveil a 6,000-pound cake
to antagonize
the leader of Turkmenistan
if you do that without
an audience in the room,
you look like a crazy person
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
You guys do have that ability to
go grand every once in a while
-Yeah.
And that necessitates
some kind of sound of joy,
not just a kind of...
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Now do you know all you
crew's coughs at this point?
-Well, see, I'm still not
operating with a crew...
-That's right.
-...so I -- there is --
The only sound I hear
is my own voice
echoing back at me from th
wall, so I hear nothing.
-Yeah.
I think I got the right --
I think 10 people
is about right.
-Honestly, I -- doing the
Edinburgh festival for years
I performed to a lot less
than 10 a lot of times.
[ Laughter ]
I can honestly --
I can honestly say,
the first couple years
I was doing Edinburgh,
when you walk up
to your stage manager --
If it was double figures,
I was like, "It's happening.
This is show business.
10 separate people?"
-My old comedy partner and I
once did a show in Chicago
for nine people, and seven
of them were blood relations
[ Laughter ]
-I had --
I had 100% walkout in Edinburgh.
-Did you really?
-Four people --
Four people in the audience.
"We got four in tonight?
Okay, great."
After about 10 minutes in,
I'm doing an hour, two leave
So now I've got two people
and it's a couple.
And this is where
it gets sadistic.
The guy gets up, says,
"I'm going to the toilet."
I'm like, "You wouldn't
do this to your wife."
And she's looking at him,
going, "Don't.
This is --
This is an abandonment issue."
He leaves. She stays
for about 20 more minutes.
And I see her hand going dow
to the floor to pick up her bag.
And I said, "Are you leaving?"
And she said, "Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
I will never, ever forget
the sound of the door
closing behind her.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, that's --
John, they really didn't
like the show because --
-Really didn't.
-I mean, for them to be able
to know that you knew...
-Yeah. I really feel --
I think about what
she must have been
going through a lot,
because she must have thought --
she must have calculated,
"There's about half an hou
of this show left.
This is --
What I'm about to do
could haunt me
for the rest of my life,
but it's half an hour more
I can't do it."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have
a glow about yourself?
Vaccinated, my friend?
-Yes.
I got my first --
I got my first shot.
So I was very -- Yeah, I'm very,
very happy about it, obviously
[ Laughter ]
-No -- I -- When I --
When I got my first shot..
-Yeah.
-...the nurse was, I think
a little surprised
at how happy I was.
The same happen for you?
-That was absolutely
the case for me.
I went in, I was kind of
shaking with excitement.
And she said, "How do you feel?"
I went,
"I'm really, really happy.
I'm so excited about this.
And she said, "Why?"
And it kind of -- it kind of
hit me a little bit odd.
Think, you know,
"Have you turned on the news
You know why we're all here?
And then she --
I said, "Well, I'm just excite
'cause the pandemic
has been really bad."
And she said,
"You're not afraid of needles?
I mean, again --
Again, I don't love them,
but it has been really bad
So I still see this
as a net positive.
Don't ruin the moment for me
-I -- I remember two thing
when I got my shot.
One, I -- I got a little -
I got a little choked up.
-Really?
-And I said to my nurse,
"I'm never gonna
forget your name."
And the other thing is,
that I do not remember her name.
[ Laughter ]
I remember that I forgot it.
-Yeah.
Well, that's -- that's the mos
important thing, isn't it?
[ Laughter ]
-I have a lot more
to ask you about.
-"It was important to me
in the moment
and I forgot all the lessons."
It feels like, on a macro scale,
that is what I worry about
with this pandemic,
that exactly what you
experienced is going to happen
All the key lessons that wer
put absolutely, blindingly
unblinkingly in front
of people's eyes --
Well, let's make a change.
Let's make a change.
We need to -- we need
to look at environmentally
how we're handling things
around the world
to not let a pandemic
like this happen again.
And it's over,
and, yeah, "What was that?
It was something
to do with bats.
I don't know.
They like grapes.
Who can stay mad at them?"
[ Laughter ]